DEFENDED BY BUTLER.
GIVE IT TO
>> Lisa: TURNOVER.
KHRIS PULLS FROM UP TOP
>> Lisa: WE HAVE A YET.
>> Marques: GET ON IT.
>> Lisa: I DEFENSE.
HERRO, IT'S SHORT.
DESERVEDLY SO.
>> Adam: MAKE IT A TWO-
POSSESSION IT
AND HOLD ON AGAINST ATLANTA!
>> Stacey: --
>> Dave: MORANT WILL TAKE THE.
>> Dave: ZIAIRE WILLIAMS.
THAT WILL IS AT THREE.
STRUCK FROM BEHINDND
COFFEY MAKES BOTH FREE THROWS.
DRIVING IN, COVINGTON PUTS 2 1/
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE GAME AND
SHOT CLOCK.
UH-OH.TEN.
LAKERS DOWN ONE.
HERE COMES THE DOUBLE.
TO YOU
CAN DO IS LET LeBRON BREAK FOR
DESMOND BANE, WITH
REBOUND, THREE-POINT GAME
FIGURES WITH 10.
>> Pete: THE BULLS ARE A VERY
ANDERSON IN THE GAME, BECAUSE
HE NEEDED A DEFE
I BELIEVE IT'S THE THIRD TIME
ON GRAPHICS, FIVE-
POINT LEAD FOR GRIZZLIES, JUST
TRYING TO GET OUT OF CHICAGO
WITH A WIN  YOU MAKE THE
FREE THROW.
THERE'S A LOT O
SHOOTERS IN THERE.
A SEASON OF SHOOTING.
THEY SAY IT'S IN AN
>> Jeff: HE FOU REALLY -- WHAT
YOU USED TO BE ABLE HIM
PRIOR TO THAT.
EXTREME CONFIDENCE IN THE E.
ABILITIES OF GORAN DRAGIC. TO GO
THAT FOUL  13 FREE
THROWS IN THIS CUT BY IRVING.
AND AGAIN,ING
AND GIANNIS ALREADY DOWN THE
COURT.
>> Mike: THIS ONE OBVIOUSLY IS
HUGE AS WELL TO MAKE HE CONNECT.
FREE THROWS FOR THE
BUCKS.
CLUTCH FREE-THROW SHOOTING THEHE
LAMELO !!  SOME
UNBELIEVABLY ATHLETIC PLAYS
HERE IN THE OVERTIME SESSION.
UL CUNNINGHAM
RIGHT HERE.   15 GAME WINNING
STREAK AGAINST DETROIT IS
THEY TIED THE TRAP. NOBODY
ON THE OFFENSIVE  LAST NOTICES.
>> Justin: OVER TO THE
NETO, LOOKING FOR SOME OF THEM.
>> Justin: MURRAY Justin: ONE
KNOCK IT OUT.
>> Justin: WALKER ES.
>> Justin: KISPERT HAS COME IN
>> Justin: AVDIJA, THE INBOUND.
MAKE A POINT PLAY TO
SHOOT THE BALL.
AND IF THERE IS ENOUGH TIME ON
THEY TRY TO TRAP MURRAY. KUZMA.
THE CORNER.
THERE.
LONNIE WALKER IV WAS WIDE OPEN
>> Drew: AND YOU WOULD BE
AMAZED AT HOW MANY TIMES GUYS
ACTUALLY THREE IS IN AIR
BALL.
MURRAY HAS GOT IT, AND THAT
THEY CALL A FOUL WHISTLE.
L.A. HAD JUGGLES.
DODGING DEFENDERS, ISHE THREE FE
TIE.
THE LONG REBOUND GOES TO COFFEY
MATTHEWS FOR THREE. 6 FOR TOWNS.
KAT FIRES,EVELAND.
EVAN MOBLEY WAS STEPPING OUT OF
BOUNDS W